welcome back to good day las vegas metro
sheriff joe lombardo joins us once again
for our morning cup of joe's segment
sheriff good to see you once again good
morning john
all right so it's still a a few months
off but we look ahead to new year's eve
as soon as the one before has just
finished and here on the las vegas strip
it's a big deal of course
but we've got covet around we've had
some issues of
crime on the strip recently what are the
plans underway right now from metro
with regards to new year's eve in las
vegas
uh so in today's
timeline or today's schedule they are
planning fireworks
uh lbcva in las vegas events wants to
move forward with the fireworks show
now as far as the county and a license
to block las vegas boulevard and for
customers pedestrians to occupy las
vegas boulevard
that is still up in the air so and
whether there's going to be any
live entertainment associated with the
event or not
that's still up in the air so we're
going week to week john
it's it's unfortunate but with the in
the
days of covid and the unknowns
associated with colgate
we still don't know what that's going to
look like